so I want to talk a little bit about PPP
funds you know when these programs were
put in place I could have gone out and
gotten PPP money to pay employees and to
pay studio rent even though we're not
using the studio right now we're still
paying rent for it because we have a
lease but when this opportunity was
presented to me I kind of thought it
through and I realized we are getting
hit because of the virus a lot of people
are canceling memberships we're having
some advertisers drop out YouTube
revenue is down but we're not really
that affected like if I was a restaurant
that was closed my revenue has just gone
to zero so I decided there's limited
money I'm not gonna take this this
funding I'm not going to do it I'm gonna
leave the money for somebody else I
opted out and some people in our
audience grabbed some memberships and
made up for a little bit of the hole we
were digging out of we've now learned
because the data has been released about
who received large amounts of money
through this government bailout program
that Kanye West's clothing line has been
bailed out Scientology the Church of
Scientology took money Kanye West's
clothing line was cleared to receive
five million dollars this is a billion
dollar brand they received five million
dollars the Church of Scientology which
is so so wealthy and a major holder of
real estate and I want to remind people
that these were loans designed in a way
where as long as the loans are used with
certain parameters like to pay for
payroll etc you don't need to repay the
money so this these were loans that are
largely forgivable if you use the money
in the prescribed ways so for churches
and other entities that don't pay taxes
they aren't paying taxes which is
ultimately where this money comes from
right as money's coming from government
revenues the taxes I pay the taxes you
pay and they are taking that money
American citizen money and then they are
receiving it and they're never going to
have to pay it back and the example I
mean there's so many examples I could
spend all day just giving you examples
the Soho House which is a membership
club controlled by a billionaire named
berkel they got loans between nine and
twenty three million dollars they
applied for a bunch of loans they have
different locations in Miami Beach in
Chicago and New York etc more than 400
country clubs and golf resorts got PPP
money the ein Rand Institute which is
all about Iran's philosophy about
self-sufficiency and not depending on
governments the ein Rand Institute who
we've done work with we've we've
interviewed people from the ioan Rand
Institute and I've moderated some
debates they took money remember I'm
Rand was against depending on government
but received welfare benefits the Iran
Institute which espouses her ideology
also got PPP bailout money so there's a
few different things here number one
this is why we need oversight and this
is why they didn't want oversight you
know the billionaire developer Joe
Farrell who builds mega mansions in the
Hamptons got a PPP loan of somewhere up
to a million dollars private jet
companies which have quickly rebounded
because rich people now instead of
flying first-class or or chartering a
private jet they're increasingly buying
private jets or private jet companies
are buying more jets in order to allow
rich people to charter them so they very
quickly recovered private jet companies
got PPP money on including jet links
aviation it's an insanely long list but
meanwhile all these small businesses
have failed
restaurant owners I know in eastern
Massachusetts and in western
Massachusetts and even in other parts of
the country they're just closing they're
done they're not coming back again again
I could have taken some PPP cash to pay
employees and cover studio rent but
because I decided you know we're not
that bad off we're not that port we're
not we're not that poorly positioned I
can just kind of go to my audience and
say listen a lot of people had to cancel
maybe you can get a $6 a month
membership like that was my ask because
I wanted to do what I thought was the
right thing so it's very disturbing to
see the way that this has gone down of
course a lot of you know it's crony
capitalism a lot of trumps friends have
gotten huge huge money but there's also
the irony
that the same people who say we
shouldn't be dependent on government are
actually the first in line for the
handouts and a lot of them are wealthy
conservatives every broke and struggling
small business owner should be furious
about what's going in going on and you
know the the right loves to claim to be
against socialism but they're against it
as long as it's not helping poor people
right when when it's not rather when
it's not helping poor people that was
confusing when it's not helping poor
people when it's helping them and their
friends all of a sudden socialism is ok
and last point on this if you know how
they always say well private companies
are gonna do better jobs at things than
the government if a private company had
screwed up the distribution of PPP funds
this badly heads would be rolling people
would be fired there would be massive
penalties and meanwhile the Trump
administration is essentially getting a
pass using with no oversight PPP money
being used as a slush fund for Trump's
friends and other people in positions of
power it's you know it's infuriating but
it's also just really sad and depressing
that this is did we really expect
anything else when Donald Trump when
Trump talks about doing infrastructure
spending he talks about doing it by
handing out contracts to his buddies you
know it's there's always some crony
capitalist background to this and we're
going to continue covering this over on
our Instagram page at David Pakman show
so make sure you're following us there
we're going to take a quick break I am
going to talk about meri Trump's book
coming up next if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink its blink Isleta consume an entire
book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
a book before you buy the entire thing I
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great Stephen Hawking this
is a book that I have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinka blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is calm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video